si sono messi a martellare in questo
preciso momento che il tempismo che c'ha
il mio condominio a posto
tutti ragazzi e poi venute me sono io
sono fa vigente oggi siamo su come si
chiama società happy wilson su è più il
gioco che non mai fatto comunque ragazzi
prima di partire volevo dirvi che questo
video non sarà l'unico di giornata ma
stasera uscirà un altro video quindi
viva le banane e la torta di mele anche
ragazzi cominciamo visto che aprì wales
non cambia mai stato ottantatreesimo
episodio manca pochissimo per
raggiungere i 100 dell'orange jetpack
rambla de loren
io ho cliccato il livello senza neanche
leggere ciao a te ora in quella di
ritorno al futuro cento vorrebbe grande
giove è proprio la delorean ragazzi lui
non sembra molto doc ma va nel futuro
sono soprattutto per il fatto che non
cade
c'è poco una macchina anti fisica
ragazzi andiamo direttamente all 8 al
centesimo episodio di harry wilson con
questa macchina del tempo
oddio mi sta cambiando no va bene figlio
siamo nel futuro nel futuro ci sono le
persone senza il corso nella testa nei
piedi né un cazzo c'è solo la gamba ci
sarà un certo risparmio sui vestiti crei
credo è un cocktail creato tanto cocktai
come cazzo hai scritto non ho capito
perché dovrebbero fare un cocktail
creato su suo happy with c'è una specie
di simulator per il barman ovan blender
hanno fatto i livelli col frullatore non
so perché oramai sono diventati la moda
adesso ragazzi mi preparo un long ciak
che è un antenato del long island un po
più vecchi ma molto saporito si usa
nonno ciak
ecco qua arrivano in ritardo dio non
messi un po troppi va bene facciamolo un
po strong che sta qua wanda impatta
subito dopo di che per farlo long si
mette
il il nero chi vuole capire capisca
chiudiamo il frullatore perfetto con lo
sportellino che sparisce caso dopodichè
ragazzi si parte con l'aggio
completamente a dieci perfetto
meraviglioso poi si lascia a triturare
per 45 minuti e 26 secondi non uno di
più i ragazzi stoppa tutto e si fa
arredi e lui non si beve un cazzo perché
rimane lì baby win bebè vi sarebbe look
no perché sono già no grazie a dio try
to win it baby speed più shift a devo
nava che figo il tratto colpito mia
sorella a caso non sa vincere con la
bambina e vabbè fatemi vincere in
qualche ma eccolo eccolo
non so ecco ho vinto io ho vinto sta
vincendo i ragazzi
non è il cocktail di prima che l'ha
fatto andare in botta non capisce più in
gas in realtà non ho vinto stati provare
a vincere col bambino il problema che
non è così semplice
picchia però ha un futuro da tuffatore
ragazza
ci dovremmo fare la prima si è l'altro
non ha toccato meraviglioso comunque
ragazzi sono il col gesso ancora perché
il telo tolto solo questo video l'ho
registrato prima di togliere il gesso
quindi sembra che ce l'ho ancora ma in
realtà non ce l'ho più che altro ha
cliccato il livello a caso non sono
anche cos'è ad evo devo devo morire
domani cioè un livello della mente ok mi
fate salire oppure devo continuare a
fare finta che bravo bravo
l'importante non è il gesto importante e
rompersi le gambe e guardarle mentre si
rompono demo dell'inferno
mi sa che non è poco sobrio che hai
scelto è certo che si chiami demo
dell'inferno e poi scrivi happy
christmas c'è sei un genio zio dove
prima uccidere il folletto solca babbo
natale non devi s'è incazzato mi ha
sentito e se inter ha vinto pure è
possibile no ragazzi non devo morire non
devono metterci boccia posso fare me lo
sento
fucà
lo vedi questo questo è il tuo regalo
zio sono sopravvissuto mentre uno mi
pupa la fava e muore quando fini da favo
e cioè babbo natale che fa altre cose
sembra delle sconce su youtube
[Musica]
fight level fixed a perché prima non
funzionava zio
sì però stai calmo calmo molto calmo è
che un tuffo tuffa vj tu tu tu tu figli
finché non sapevo scrivere cose brutte
non scrivere cose toufigh a thing to
fight
bene anche voi con the fighter mano al
pensavo peggio conquistate tutti calmi
perché siamo partiti male ho detto che
devi stare calma cosa non hai capito
della parola calmo
spiegami hulk questo ti sembra hulk e
meno ricordato un po diverso dai che
sono razzista e pro era verde come mi ha
colpito che non è possibile cioè stavo
mi stavo coprendo non è possibile tensor
levin ragazzi alla fine ha vinto luke
non si sa perché ne percorre ma ha vinto
sto deficiente ora lo zio a bravo da noi
casati perché seriamente sei un fenomeno
e qualcuno non braccio ragazzi lo regalo
ed alla jolie all'entrata con questa
veramente assumendo gran significato è
più visto nel tempo e ve lo dico secondo
me si parlerà di questo nei libri di
storia e un giorno ovvero ragazzi che se
non c'era la barriera hanno vinto lui
dos tre ave mannaia la putain ama
mannaia proprio come si può fare un
livello legge ma se la vittoria
guarda ma guarda qualcuno è possibile
eli eli e salta fuori ma non erano a 6
assurdo eva
sì sì sì cos'è cazzo oggetto phinet fred
ma no è tornato come ho fatto tornare
indietro hanno cliccato niente la tosse
su google che vi è più di salvare il suo
video solo questo cioè gli altri fan
tutti cagare questo è l'unico che appare
non so perché face e pino favi io mi
chiamo lory anno non so se ridere per
loriano per facebook pino a questo dito
voglio vedere come riesco a giocare con
questa roba qui c'è sarà un'impresa
titanica frate please fa il sito che è
meglio ma zitto proprio o povero
cristiano che c'è al dito fasciato che
non riesce a giocare mi dispiace zio
veramente non so come hai fatto spyphone
sinceramente non mi ricordo l'ultima
volta che ho fatto uno spy phone
spero che però che fosse andata meglio
quella volta che questa era impossibile
cioè o troppo avanti
[Musica]
mi è rientrata la gamba nel deretano
fortissimo sguardo troppo star wars e
mancava solo il livello di fv su star
wars che tanto ormai hanno fatto anche
la carta igienica di star wars steve io
sono tuo padre
ecco perché bisognerebbe farla con luke
è questa io che sono tuo padre c'è un
senso però non c'è quel bastardo quando
ti serve non c'è mai la spada via cos'è
che che si sa è il senso sei uno sforzo
tra di esistere
ragazzi ho usato la forza
no ragazzi il risveglio della forza ha
un senso adesso effettivamente
fantastico sono io che domino qua altro
che primo ordine e vabbè comunque a
parte sto casino come faccia vincere non
vinco
so di aver vinto da gloria me la tengo
dentro di me perfetti piccioni ce l'ha
scritto premier premere contro il più w
e io ho premuto contro il pw e mi si è
chiusa la pagina di happy with ma si
fotte sega
caroline
si si si stava ascoltando questa sì sì
lo so sono io che ascolto canzone
comunque ragazzi è un record perché in
un episodio solo sono riuscito a
chiudere per due volte cioè miracoloso
sta roba
però io senza di andy si ok kinda cruz 9
posso far di meglio di otto lo prometto
ecco infatti ce l'ha fatta good mark
player no no non esattamente mark layer
per ora ci proviamo dimora ok ok
perfetto dal servizio su ma player
invece no pd poi a me è già qualcosa di
più costiero
cos'è allora vai vai vai vai vai vai zio
ma zio e vabbè perché io il mio fidato
mister mietitrebbia siamo inseparabili
grandissimo altro che più di piper rari
ferrari
vabbè madonna che sfiga non abbia regala
fatta benissimo su è più i si è fatta
benissimo fermi tutti
la madonna
però c'è ancora la mano sul cruscotto
quindi possesso vinto hanno vinto il
simbolo della ferrari e quello fatto
meglio
sembra il bicchiere dei cocktail o un
clistere uno dei due allora è calmiamo
se tutti un attimo affetto madonna però
ma anche moglie maggie in questa ferrari
c'e va bene che c'è una macchina da un
cristo di alberghi che poi cosa le dico
a mia moglie quando tornerà in tutto
imbrattato di sangue cioè si incazza
juncker ha già sentite e sta diventando
per quanto strano suo livello problema è
che cosa fa cosa se come stava guidando
spiegate
[Musica]
perfetto
sonia fatta bello bravo nonno se il più
grande pilota di ferrari che io abbia
mai visto complimenti poi vj slime 13
perché ogni tanto allora fixed verso
l'ultimo della saga favi james nei dj
alla fine riceverà un premio se lo gioca
a vai su con l'ascensore vado su zio il
proprio io voglio il premio comunque non
ne frega niente ormai è lei detto e
mantieni bravo fa vj bravo paese la
minchia sono morto calre piano piano
piano è la madonna ai vai vai vai
perfetto bravo fa vj un altro passo sue
sei arrivato va bene adoeno sono gioco
di ascensore ma che divertente che bello
non ho parole
questo è questo il mio premio ma è
bellissimo
[Musica]
provo fuori già arrivato per il premio
grazie grazie a zero grazie ficano avevo
bisogno grazie per la giocata fuori
disney per favore darci una valutazione
più risponde allego sempre grazie grazie
ti meriti si meriti tutto il mondo i
meriti la vita ti meriti voto più
genuino che possa dare a questo livello
veramente incredibile e questo è il mio
voto zio è proprio questo che ragazzi
con crollo prima pillola che è stato
alquanto strano riuscire a fare i
livelli di nata visto che siamo arrivati
a natale per il prossimo episodio mi
immagino proprio tutto fatto di natale
però non è ancora detto speriamo si
inventino qualcosa ragazze e ragazzi
miei spero che mi sia piaciuto e cosa il
dotto video è piaciuto il suo documento
è un mi piace ai capace di facebook e
con i video tra schizzi a se stessi
iscritti ci vediamo al prossimo visto
che la ragazza
[Musica]